[Musique]
loin du vacarme des villes et des
combines du show business c'est dans
cette modeste demeure que vit la famille
clapiers autrement dit lors qu'est ce tu
es banques la crise
il y a le père rené clapiers artisan
menuisier
la maire marie clapiers excellente
ménagères et fin cordon-bleu
[Musique]
la fille mireille clapiers 24 ans qui
seconde sa maman dans les travaux de la
maison et du jardin
et puis enfin le fils edm en clapiers
chauffeur de car c'est lui qui assure
chaque jour le ramassage scolaire des
enfants du village et c'est surtout le
chef d'orchestre edmond clapiers le plus
célèbre de l'arrondissement de saint
philippe
[Musique]
maintenant
ma grand mère m'a dit guillaume sitl
syndicats étude jette un accordéon
finalement j'aurais eu et ça a traîné
quelques temps j'y pensais plus buts et
un jour ça m'a pris j'ai voulu accorder
au projet crème à g et la match très
accroché et ça a débuté comme ça et
injurié des copines je ne me chercher
pour les jouets nausées puis en a qui
monte en donnant à jouer 2 3 puis vient
me l'a fait emballer puis de libye et
après vous avez embauché la vie et après
on a pris la famille à les parties
[Musique]
bonjour
on va bien s'amuser bonjour
vite entré dans la danse car nous allons
prendre et de broc
il invite à apprendre la guitare et tu
m'as tu m'accompagnes là et puis ça mais
tu prendras mûri et papa la batterie
36.6 médias y voient un fils parti comme
ça
[Musique]
il
comment vous avez appris la musique
mairie mais c'est à dire qu'en finale à
metz j'ai eu mon frère m'a dit tu après
nationalitaire pour m'accompagner n'ont
pas pas un soir en revenant dit qu elle
m'a dit faut qu après la musique et rien
à faire tu avanceras pas lent le soir il
m'a à la veillée après les études il m'a
dit on va apprendre la musique dans une
veillée j'ai appris la musique en une
seule veiller à une visible et vous
jouez loin d'ici quelques mois jusqu'à
2,5 kilomètres à vous déplacer beaucoup
joué on a eu à dire clairement on
regarde dans la loge elle en avait long
à faire du mode de new cynophiles
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on appelle la case as il ya
beaucoup de caisses qui jouent ils n'ont
pas de gala sur les affaires surprise
parce qu il faut les entretenir
et vous vous avez la cadence je sais ce
qu'on a pu
[Musique]
n'hésitez pas
pour
ne peut on pas de gagner
m
pour moi
à pied qu'est-ce que vous éprouvez quand
vous êtes sur les stades et votre
famille moi je suis contente pierre
pierre 2 vous pensiez pas départ où l'on
jamais dans ma vie des mauriciens qui
ont jamais j'aurais pu croire qu'un jour
vraiment on le verrait sur les affiches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]